Every day, the world consumes 300 tons of caffeine,...
...enough for one cup of coffee for every man, woman and child.
It takes about 40 coffee beans to make one shot of espresso.
Poison though caffeine is, you do still develop an addiction to this stuff.
And it's a real physiological addiction, not a wimpy psychological addiction...
...like people claim for video games and the Internet.
But caffeine isn't heroin, rapid withdrawal won't kill you.
It might make you cranky and give you a wicked headache...
...but since caffeine releases dopamine to make you happy and it gets rid of headaches,...
...there's really no reason to ever stop using this stuff.
Caffeine is the world's most used psychoactive drug and with good reason, it's pure awesome.
It increases concentration, decreases fatigue and gives you better memory.
And this isn't just a placebo, these are real effects replicable in a laboratory.
And, contrary to popular belief, drinking coffee isn't a Faustian bargain where the Devil...
...gives you the ability to work faster but in exchange, makes your life shorter.
For normal, healthy humans, there are no medical concerns.
Coffee and the caffeine within it may even have medical benefits...
...such as protection from cardiovascular disease, diabetes and Parkinson's.
Caffeine can even get rid of migraines,...
...but the amount required and the method of ingestion is... uncomfortable.
You know what else you can thank caffeine for?
A little thing called the Enlightenment.
In the 1600s, people drank more beer and gin than water.
But with the introduction of coffee and tea, people switched from a depressant to a stimulant.
It's not surprising then that this time was an intellectual boon compared to earlier centuries.
Ben Franklin and Edward Lloyd loved their coffee for the same reason that modern workers and students do.
It's invaluable for staying awake and concentrating when you need to finish a TPS report...
...or to get through that boring physics class.
Coffee is the fuel of the modern world...
...so go grab a cup guilt-free and get working smarter and faster.